I am going with saving privately damn it
yeah dude bro I mean come on dude I
think that was everyone's number one the
first couple scenes when they take
Normandy when you see the guy carrying
his own arm the creativity they asked
him and the writer they're like was that
based off real like uh first person
accounts and they go nah but it could
have been everyone in the squad is
awesome Barry Pepper as the religious
sniper Eddie Burns as the handsome cool
New Yorker Tom Sizemore as the
psychopath wild man you need one in
every Squad if I could only take one guy
from the movie and I had a real army
unit that I had to take into into battle
I would take Barry Pepper he's also a
lefty but all the guns are for writing
so he has to go over to do this
and he's so efficient at it and I was
just like I just thought that was such a
it's like Jimi Hendrix was playing
backwards on the guitar right yeah
there's rumors that Vin Diesel was
giving Spielberg directing advice in
between takes
that's amazing dude